at this altitude I can run flat out for
my hands this episode is brought to you
by peloton
I love peloton peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right to your home you
don't have to worry about fitting
classes into your schedule making it to
the studio or dealing with some commute
to the gym I have a peloton bike in my
master bedroom at home and it is one of
the first things that I do in the
morning I wake up meditate for 20
minutes and then I knock out a short 20
minute ride usually high-intensity
interval training or hit then I take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's beautifully
convenient and has become something that
I actually look forward to and I was
skeptical in the beginning I didn't
think I would dig it and I really do so
you have a lot of options for one if you
like you can ride it live with thousands
of other peloton riders from across the
country on the interactive leaderboard
to keep you motivated I tend to use a
lot of the classes on demand and have
four to six of them that I've bookmarked
and use over and over again there are up
to 14 new classes every day with
thousands of classes on demand and there
are a variety of workouts to choose from
45 minute classes 20 minute burns hip
hop rock and roll low impact or
high-intensity pick the class structure
and style there works for you
peloton has an amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
they really do have great instructors of
every possible personality and style and
you can find one that you love no matter
what you're in the mood for personally I
use Matt wolbers a lot but I use a bunch
of them I'm promiscuous and enjoy
classes from a lot of their instructors
with real time metrics you can track
your performance over time and continue
to beat your personal bests
I did not think the gamification would
work for me and they really hit the nail
on the head it does work at least for me
tremendously well to keep me pushing
consistently so discover this
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings us to do experience to your home
peloton is offering listeners of this
pod
a limited time offer go to one pallet on
Comm that's spelled o-n-e PE l OT o n
com
enter the code tim podcast on one word
at checkout and get $100 off accessories
with your peloton bike purchase get a
great workout at home anytime you want
go to one peloton calm and use the code
tim podcast to get started this episode
of the tim ferriss show is brought to
you by 99 designs 99 designs is a global
creative platform that makes it easy for
you to find an amazing designer and
create designs you'll love from logos to
branding to packaging to books you name
it they have it and I've used them for
just about everything 99 designs is the
go to creative resource for any budget
I've used them for years now for book
covers for instance mock-ups of the
4-hour body which went on to become a
number one New Times bestseller
illustrations for the multi-volume Tao
of Seneca including the cover and many
other creative projects I've been very
impressed by the quality of their work
most recently I used 99 designs to
update the illustrations and layout of
my five morning rituals ebook the
illustrations worked out great I loved
working with the designer we selected
and I plan to work with him on more
projects in the future and that's
something you can do you don't have to
start from scratch every time and right
now my listeners can get $20 off plus a
free $99 upgrade on their first design
contest simply submit a brief on the
site describing what you need and
designers who are interested in your
project often from around the world will
submit concepts for you to choose from
you refined as you go give feedback and
once you're ready you choose one to
finalize it's a great way to get started
and find the right match a great
designer and a great design at a great
price so head to 99designs comm forward
slash Tim to learn more or get started
today you can also see examples of some
of the work that I have done with
designers on 99designs so check it out
99 designs dot-com forward slash tip
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
I'm very very excited for this episode
and my guest because he's had such a
tremendous impact in my life and I
haven't seen him in quite a long time so
let's just jump right into the bio which
does not quite do you justice we're
gonna dig into some things that have
been artfully omitted here hedge Shou
Shou spelled Zhi SCH a you who is
currently among many other things
interim president of Sierra Nevada
college which is a pro bono assignment
he's accepted much much earlier he
founded system industries in Palo Alto
California in 1969 and as its CEO led it
to a successful IPO in 1980 in the 1990s
he was the general manager of the IBM
storage systems division headquartered
in San Jose California
I believe that was one a six billion
dollar business something along those
lines and we'll come back to that
Edie has a total of ten years of
teaching experience as a professor in
the Graduate Business School at Stanford
University and Harvard University and he
has taught high tech entrepreneurship
courses for a total of 22 years in the
engineering schools at Princeton
University Caltech and the University of
nevada-reno
in addition to serving on the boards of
major public companies such as Reader's
Digest and star tech it has helped to
start and build several technology
companies during the past 20 years some
of which were founded and led by his
former students and I've met many many
of EDS former students who have started
and built tremendous companies in the
1980s Eadie represented the Silicon
Valley area of California for two terms
in the US House of Representatives
serving on the House Foreign Affairs
Committee also during the 1980s he was a
General Partner of Brentwood associates
a venture capital firm and he was the
founding chairman of the tech
interactive which I lived very close to
back when I was in California formerly
known as the Tech Museum of innovation
and non profit educational institution
in San Jose California
it holds an a/b degree [ __ ] laude and
philosophy bridging with physics from
Princeton University as well as an MBA
MS statistics and PhD degrees from
Stanford University and a Doctor of Laws
degree honoris causa hope in getting my
Latin correctly
the University of San Francisco
currently he is a senior fellow of the
California Council on science and
technology you have three children nine
grandchildren and I'm gonna leave out
your exact resident specificity just
because of the size of the audience
Edie welcome to the show oh it's great
to be here with you too
I think back to the spring semester of
2000 when you contacted me after all of
the other students had registered for my
course and made such an impressive plea
to be able to enroll in the course
committing if you were enrolled that you
would clean the blackboards clean the
erasers do whatever it took to make my
life easier and I almost cried when I
heard those words and you took the
course and I'm so proud of what you've
done over the past 19 years I don't
blame the course for your success
but I I do blame your enrolling in the
course for our friendship and you've
taught me so much from the very
beginning I and III I wanted to take the
course for many many reasons this was
ele 491 high tech entrepreneurship which
was in the electrical engineering
department in the ORF Department which I
can never remember the actual full name
for operations and research relations
research and financial engineering there
we go now I have I have no business
whatsoever being in any engineering
school but at the time the the Princeton
courses undergraduate courses were only
very recently being voted on by students
this was a very new thing this is before
Yelp and so on and one of the standouts
was this new course high tech
entrepreneurship taught by Professor
Chou
and I really wanted like many people to
be part of this course and when I when I
finally was accepted to the course and
began learning I remember one point I
was cleaning the blackboard and cleaning
the erasers and you said to me I don't
you remember this you said Tim don't get
too good at cleaning the erasers and
there was there's a lot of direct
teaching and a lot of indirect teaching
just observing you as you interact with
your students and the world and there
there are certain things that when I
described you to my friends and I do
that very often and a lot of your
students I mean you're just telling me
before we began recording stay in touch
with you and these are people from 4050
years ago
it's it's it's remarkable and one of the
things I throw in that was not in the
bio I read was figure skating could you
please tell us about your background
with figure skating I grew up in Omaha
Nebraska and we were fortunate to have
an indoor skating rink where a
professional ice hockey team played the
Omaha Knights they they were probably a
farm team for one of the NHL hockey
teams and my mother took me to that ice
rink when I was about seven years old
and I really enjoyed the challenge and I
remember coming back from one session
when I was just beginning to skate and I
said mom I I really had a good day today
and she said what was so special about
it and I said I only felt 40 times this
is this time and from what you might
call small beginnings I began to get
more proficient and more interested and
in those days
figure skating was really figure skating
where there were precise patterns on
clean ice with turns
and loops that you had to perform in
order to pass certain tests and I passed
the pretest and then I passed the first
test and the second test and at that
point I was kind of on my way but the
ice was only available during the winter
so I when I was 13 I began spending
summers away from Omaha where there were
ice rinks and continued to train and
continue to pass tests and when I was 16
years old I had passed the sixth test
and I qualified for the national
championships in men's singles in a
lower group not the the world class
group but a lower group and I was also
ice dancing was a partner and in 1956 we
won the silver dance championship in the
mid western sections there were three
sections in the country went to the
national championships and then the my
senior year in high school 1957 again I
skated in the national championships in
in Berkeley California I never was a
winner but it was a special experience
to meet a lot of people throughout the
country going to these championships and
I still stay in touch with my dance
partner and a gentleman who I competed
against in the singles championships it
was a big part of my life Tim and and as
I think about it the hours that I spent
training getting up at 6 a.m. or
actually 5:30 a.m. being on the ice in
Omaha at 6 a.m. in a cold winter
Nebraska winter and then skating in the
evening to fitting in homework school to
prepare for one competition where
if you did well enough you could go to
the national championships it taught me
a the power the value of practice of
dedication of persistence and
determination those are valuable life
lessons and character building lessons
so when people ask me well how do I
prepare to be a leader or to change the
world it's through learning those values
you don't get a quick return creating
value for the world you get a quick
return doing something that doesn't
matter but if you're going to make a
difference in the society changing the
world for the better
you better be prepared for a long
journey you to me as one of your
standout characteristics have
preparation you have you're very
meticulous preparation I remember this
because keep in mind people listening as
we said I was showing up to potentially
do my chalkboard duty and my eraser duty
and so on so I would arrive to Le 491
early and you would be arranging the
name cards so you had placards for the
students which is not common at
Princeton so you'd have you'd have the
name cards you'd be arranging chairs and
reviewing potentially the case study
materials and I don't remember any TAS
any teaching assistants for that class
so could you talk about how you thought
about preparation outside of say figure
skating and did that come from your
parents where did that attention to
detail before the competition whether
that's a competition and business sports
or otherwise or just getting up in front
of a class of students can you talk to
where that comes from and how you think
about preparation well I was a strong
believer in Murphy's Law whatever can go
we'll go over long yeah and so I would
come to the classroom
typically 45 minutes early make sure
that the projector was working I didn't
want and and sometimes it wasn't yeah
and so I had time then to call the
audiovisual people and they'd come over
and get it fixed rather than showing up
right at the time the class starts and
then finding that there are problems
that disrupted the flow of the of the
class I think it was Benjamin Franklin
who wrote failing to prepare is
preparing to fail and and so it's it's
very important to me not to be surprised
by things that go wrong and the way that
you prevent that is through preparation
and making sure everything is the way
that it needs to be for success as far
as the class is concerned even though I
had taught the lessons the sessions many
many times I usually spent two to three
hours prior to each class preparing
again I viewed my classes which were
taught by the case method of teaching
and learning where students would read
about an actual company situation and
put themselves in the position of the
CEO or the founder or the technical
person and describe what to do I would
ask questions and they would give the
answers and I felt that that that
approach to teaching and learning
putting someone in the position of the
of the founder or the person who had to
achieve the results rather than just
listening and learning and reading from
a book would not only
help to to learn but also build the
confidence that they could do that a
kind of job well in order to make that
experience that classroom experience
work the best it was like a performance
yeah I would I would come in and I
didn't know exactly how the discussion
would evolve but I knew the lessons that
would come out of it and I'd find a way
regardless of what the students would
say to convey those lessons through
their words in the the case method is
something I'd love to talk a little bit
more about because my first exposure to
the case method was in your class and
it's a method that as I understand it is
used at Harvard Business School also at
Stanford Graduate School of Business
what I also found so appealing about the
case method is you'd as a student have
these these short modules these case
studies and they would often be here a
part one with a cliffhanger right so the
so the module one would end with some
type of dilemma or a disaster or a big
decision and you didn't have the
conclusion you didn't you didn't have
the answer meaning what actually
happened in that particular case and it
allowed you to think for yourself but it
also gave you an opportunity to speak to
the class to speak to you and to be
assertive also because you would have I
remember at least in my in my class many
differing opinions some of which were
polar opposites and it's it really
struck me as a as a pragmatic way to
allow people to be active in the way
that they're gonna have to be active if
they're ultimately going to be
entrepreneurs when you're teaching and
learning about
starting enterprises or creating
something new you learn by doing and so
it the case method helps in that
projects that are real help it do that
one of the Princeton graduates three
that's now four years ago wrote her
senior thesis on can entrepreneurship be
taught or is it something you're born
with and there are articles that have
been written that college courses in
entrepreneurship were waste of time they
don't matter so in 2015 when she was
working on this I created an online
survey instrument which I sent out to
all 1,600 Princeton students that I had
had in my classes over thirty one
semesters and we had to cut off the
responses in order for her to meet her
thesis deadline after four hundred
responses of the sixteen hundred but of
those first sixteen hundred responses a
hundred and sixty had been founders of
companies and among the survey questions
was the question what Princeton
experiences have helped you and choose
in your life paths and succeeding in
what you pursued and of the hundred and
sixty founders ninety-five percent said
it was the course that made the
difference and I think what it was it's
not so much what they learned in detail
but rather pointing out to the students
that this is a possible life path that
you can create something from scratch
and create value and
what great satisfaction you get from
that it also and I attribute this to the
case method gave students the confidence
they could do it they'd read the case
and say I'm as smart as that person I
know I could do that too and I tried to
choose the cases with youthful founders
rather than old people like me and then
there were some tools that techniques
that they learned from it but I believe
that everyone is born with the desire to
do something beyond themselves and as an
entrepreneur starting something from
scratch making it real impacting the
world in that way it fulfills that
desire to do something meaningful beyond
themselves is that what an entrepreneur
is to you I mean if you were to define
entrepreneurs that's someone who who
built something from scratch whatever
that might be how do you think about the
term entrepreneur you probably remember
this Tim from the course but I assert
that entrepreneurship isn't about
starting companies entrepreneurship is
an approach to life and you can be an
entrepreneur in anything it's about
starting something from scratch it's
about making good things happen that
hadn't been done before it's a
combination of innovation a lot of
people get ideas and implementation and
that second part implementation is the
most important a lot of people say
wouldn't it be neat if we could do this
and that's as far as it goes but
entrepreneurs say wouldn't it be neat if
we could do this and then they do it
I want to say a few things and
underscore a couple of things the first
is that there are only two courses I
still have all the notes from meaning
courses classes I took as an undergrad
that I still have three-ring binders
which contain all the notes from one was
the literature of fact the John McPhee
and the other was ele 491 so I still
have all of those notes and I it strikes
me that first from a just from a tool
perspective if people want to find case
studies that are used at places like
Harvard Business School or Stanford
Business well you can actually find
quite a few online and in order them so
I would encourage people to look into
that the reason that I have notes from
those two classes is I think in large
part because I had and we were talking
about this a little bit earlier a very
very difficult and dark period in my
life junior year and took some time off
of school was very very hard time for me
and what I found in the literature of
fact and also particularly in high tech
entrepreneurship was a a teaching and
reinforcing of optimism right which is
very different from giving all of your
students rose-colored glasses you are
showing that and I found this to really
personally very helpful in these case
studies a lot of things go wrong but you
were able to show how people figured it
out and how they learned to navigate
around those things how do you think
about if you do the role of optimism in
any of this well I'm a chronic optimist
and I believe that that is important to
doing things that haven't been done
before you can imagine all of the things
that can go wrong and I guess there's
some value in
being a realist but I don't think you do
things that haven't been done before and
succeed in that by being negative and
focusing act on the all of the things
that need to be done rather it's having
a vision and then committing to making
it real and I with less that way I just
look at the world
I don't think through rose-colored
glasses no but I when when people say
that's going to be hard I said it's
gonna be more fun then because doing
something that's hard is a lot more fun
than doing something with these how did
you ask two questions I'll start with
the the one that sprawl I asked first
which is when you were say 20 years old
15 or 20 somewhere in that range what
did you think you were going to be when
you grew up I knew exactly what I was
gonna be all right at that I was going
to be a physicist and I came to
Princeton in 1957 with a plan to major
in physics and then in my sophomore year
I discovered philosophy and I thought
this is way cool stuff and I decided
that I would major in philosophy with in
those days what was called a bridge
program with physics so I took all of
the required courses in physics and but
my department was the philosophy
department my independent work both as a
junior and senior were on subjects that
combined philosophy and physics my
senior thesis was describing what the
German philosopher Immanuel Kant theory
of space and time
would have been had he been born fifty
years later and had known Einstein's
general theory of relativity and I
described in my thesis this is what
cants theory of space and time would
have been unfortunately he didn't know
general relativity based it on Newtonian
physics but as a presumptuous
twenty-one-year-old I figured I knew
what was inside cants head and if he
just known about Einstein and in his
theories he would have had a different
philosophy of space and time that and
two dollars and 40 cents will get you a
cup of coffee at your favorite coffee
shop and you mention Einstein I mean the
Princeton certainly has a storied
history in some respects with with
physics you know Einstein spent time not
not too far away from where we're
sitting right now and Richard Fineman
and others certainly I is that how you
ended up focusing on on Princeton and
physics it was was the was the the
history I guess at that point I'm not
sure what specifically would have drawn
you here but is that what drew you to
Princeton
well starting from the time that I was
about 12 I was an Einstein lover I guess
you'd say I began reading about his
theories and biographies and and so
forth and so I applied to various
colleges in the physics department
engineering physics in one case and
physics and all the others and I was
accepted to all of those schools and all
of them provided me with a rather
attractive scholarship except Princeton
Princeton wrote to me and said you can
work in the dining hall as a busboy
oi and I think I could make with 12 to
15 hours a week 400 dollars a semester
and I chose Princeton because I
concluded that must be the toughest
school they're not making a big deal out
of me and I want to go where it's most
challenging I've never looked back did
you end up finding Princeton challenging
Oh way too challenging and at that end
of my figure skating career I did not
have the time to continue to practice I
tried to compete in my freshman year in
the Eastern championships and didn't do
that well and I began to realize that I
wasn't going to make it and looking back
I don't know whether I would have ever
made the world team but in 1961 many of
the skaters that I had either competed
with trained with my skating coach all
perished in a plane crash the world team
on their way to the World Championships
in Brussels Belgium in 1961 and we lost
a whole generation of world class figure
skaters and I don't know whether I would
have ever gotten to that point but I'm
glad I made the choice that I did to go
to Princeton to give up figure skating
and to focus on what's led me to be here
talking to you when did teaching enter
the picture what what did you what
happened after if you could just paint a
picture for us after your your
undergraduate experience well I knew
what I was gonna do after I graduated
from Princeton I had applied for and was
accepted to the u.s. Navy officers
Candidate School in Newport Rhode Island
to begin my training in September of
1961 I went back home to Omaha Nebraska
worked in manual labor
the night shift in a can factory and in
late August was called to Ford Omaha to
be inducted into the u.s. Navy during
that pre-induction interview I was asked
if anything had happened to me
health-wise since I'd applied in
February and had it physical loan I said
well I broke my leg in a rugby game at
Princeton in April but it's fine now
they didn't take my word for it they
ordered an x-ray and concluded it wasn't
up to Navy standards so I was unable to
enter OCS in September of 1961 very
disappointed I did have an alternative I
had applied to Stanford Business School
for the MBA program I only applied to
Stanford because it only had one essay
in the application and all the others
had three so I on on Stanford for that
reason I had been accepted and I never
sent in the postcard that indicated that
I was not coming so I retrieved the
postcard sent it in and within oh I'd
say six days my whole life changed from
going into the Navy to going to
California and entering the MBA program
I did not know in that split-second in
April when I heard a crack when I fell
in the rugby game that that would change
my life so dramatically and that's why I
tell people who asked me about career
planning that career planning is
overrated you asked me the question
though how did you get into teaching
well I was in the MBA program at
Stanford University and there just like
fall
ah Sophie at Princeton I discovered
operations research applying mathematics
to real operating business problems but
operating problems in general and I said
this is way cool and so rather than
looking for a job as I was approaching
my MBA degree I applied for the ph.d
program to pursue operations research
and after my first year in the ph.d
program the professor who had taught the
most popular second-year MBA course
electronic data processing it was the
only course that stand for Business
School at that time that had anything to
do with computers he's left unexpectedly
and I went to the Dean of the business
school and I said mr. Dean you have a
problem he's got a hundred second-year
MBA students signed up to take business
366 electronic data processing this
September and you don't have anybody to
teach it I am the solution to your
problem
I can teach that course and they said
something like don't call us we'll call
you
and in late August about four three
weeks before the course was to begin I
get a call Eady
can you teach that course I said you bet
and that's how I began my teaching
career again there's a life lesson here
opportunities unexpectedly happen and
many people say gee that's an
interesting opportunity but it only
matters in life if you seize the moment
if you take advantage of that
opportunity and commit yourself to do
something that
you've never done before I find that I
learned the most the fastest when I
don't know what my I'm doing and and so
I'd never taught a university course and
all of a sudden I'm in front of a
hundred second-year MBA students 24
years old teaching a course but I did
okay and then a Stanford Graduate School
of Business said would you teach another
course I just taught different courses
and that's how my teaching career began
how did you become good at teaching or
study teaching refine your teaching how
did you how did you work on that because
you're an excellent teacher there are
plenty of bad teachers out there plenty
of passable teachers even at incredible
institutions but I would consider you a
very very adept teacher how did you how
did you learn to teach I think I became
a better teacher by not being smart and
here's what I mean by it people who are
really super smart learning comes too
easy
I believe you can be a better teacher
when it's more difficult for you to
learn so that you can explain to
somebody else how to master some lesson
I was I also had the chance as a high
school senior to take a course in debate
it was a full year course in debating
and that helped me with public speaking
but more importantly the high school
teacher who taught debate also taught
the various individual events like
oratory
and extemporaneous speaking and i wanted
to compete in extemporaneous speaking
what is could you just define what that
what that means in this guest so well
this is the way it was in when I was in
high school an extemporaneous speaking
contest a each participant individually
would be given a topic on which to speak
for 10 minutes and they were each
contestant would have one hour to
prepare the ten minute speech so my high
school teacher said will come in after
school's over every afternoon and I'll
give you a topic I'll give you an hour
and then you come back and give your ten
minute speech on that topic so the first
time I did that he gave me a topic I
spent the hour preparing I gave my talk
and when I ran out of words
I said it's the ten minutes up yet and
he says it's only been three minutes and
but every afternoon he would do that and
by the end of the public speaking events
that year the contest that year I'd
become a state champion and
extemporaneous speaking you asked
earlier Tim about preparation this is
just another example I wasn't born to be
a speaker I wasn't born to be a teacher
but I learned to do both and there are
tools also as you mentioned in your own
teaching there are tools that you can
give people and strategies which is
certainly part was part of ele 491 in in
my case and in the cases of your
students with the extemporaneous
speaking what were some of the
what were some of the keys to getting
better were there any techniques or
strategies or ways of thinking about the
topics you were given that were
particularly helpful yeah in that final
event
I remember the topic it was what was the
significance of the conflict between
Aaron Burr and Alexander Hamilton and I
had an hour to prepare that one for
Google before Google and and so this
style of presentation it wasn't a sort
of matter of fact it was to prepare what
might be called a ten minute oration
with drama with stories with life
lessons and sort of end on a crescendo
and let's go back to teaching
I view teaching more about nurturing
about personal values about inspiration
about recognizing that you can have fun
doing great things and it it's not so
much what the lessons or the facts but
rather it's it's building a maybe even
contagion this optimistic attitude and
understanding that if you can change the
world for the better you that's that's
as good as it gets
yeah I do think the you know in
retrospect it's maybe easier of course
easier see in retrospect but how these
various chance opportunities and
encounters with philosophy
with the teaching with the
extemporaneous speaking not necessarily
in that order but how they've combined
into this alchemy that has enabled you
to transmit and infuse these beliefs to
your students in a way that is very very
memorable right it's not just the text
in the book what do you remember I mean
you remember the topic Aaron Burr and so
on do you remember any of the choices
that you made in in how you competed
with that competition oh and in speaking
yeah no I remember my debate partner at
in high school and then at Princeton he
was one year behind me we had started
kindergarten together and then I skipped
first grade so I was one year ahead of
him but when he was a junior and I was a
senior he we were debate partners in a
debate team there were two on each side
and one you were assigned whether you
were the affirmative speakers behind and
supporting the resolution or the
negative speakers against the resolution
and I remember he was the first
affirmative speaker and I was sitting
near while he was standing and he got
confused and he gave the negative case
and I'm sort of making hand signals to
him as he's giving the negative case
against the resolution he's supposed to
be speaking for and I was gonna have to
follow up on this and he finally
realized what was happening and he was
so smooth he said and that ladies and
gentlemen is what our opponents would
lead you to believe however
and then he quickly switched to the
affirmative okay
that's incredible but there's also a
lesson in this that things sometimes
don't work out exactly the way you plan
but you've got to adapt and figure out
how to segue into what will work
see you strike me as very very adaptable
in so many ways I mean you've you've
spent time in so many different worlds
and you're very good at seizing
opportunities but you've also done
certain things for periods of time if
you've run companies for extended
periods of time you're in politics for
for instead period of time how do you
this is actually some phrasing that I
heard from Rabbi Jonathan Sacks in the
UK said you know how do you
differentiate between opportunities to
be seized and temptations to be resisted
so when because there's a do you've you
focused for extended periods of time on
single things when no doubt there are
other opportunities being thrown at you
how do you think about focusing for
extended periods or opening yourself to
opportunities this is really a simple
question and it's answered with one word
commitment
I had situations where I had
opportunities to leave companies that I
was running I would not leave until it
was appropriate to leave where there was
a successor there was success when
you're an entrepreneur and people are
investing in you when you're an
entrepreneur and a CEO and employees and
customers and suppliers are counting on
you you've got to have a commitment to
do the job until you're no longer
necessary when I took the company public
my
first company public and it was about a
10-year period and there were times
during that ten years where we almost
went under but when we had gone public
and I could and then did a secondary
financing so there was sufficient
capital and then did a search for a
successor
I felt that then I could leave to run
for the Congress perfect segue why why
did you decide to run for Congress I
thought I could be good and and here's
why it wasn't just gee that's way cool
like philosophy and operations research
in 1977 I was on the board of directors
of the American electronics Association
and electronics companies during the 70s
were unable to raise sufficient amounts
of risk capital the amount of capital
committed to professionally managed
venture capital funds during the 1970s
funds that would be investing in tech
companies was only 50 million a year Wow
50 million year and I was asked to chair
a task force for the American
Electronics Association on capital
formation to figure out what to do and I
assembled a group of entrepreneurs and
investors and we concluded the single
inhibitor to sufficient quantities of
risk capital investment was the high
rate of the capital gains tax at the
federal level at that time which was 50
percent and looking at it if it investor
invested and lost money they lost all
the money if they invested and made
money they gave half of it to the
federal government forgetting about what
they'd have to give it to the state
government so we felt that lower in the
tax on count
Gaines was essential to stimulating the
environment for risk capital investment
not just for electronics companies but
all kinds of job-creating ventures and
the the task force put together a white
paper and usually that's the end of the
story
well we've proposed the lower in the
capital gains tax but keep in mind Tim
that this is a group of entrepreneurs
and entrepreneurs don't just talk about
it they make stuff happen and so the
first thing we did is we did a survey of
our the electronics industry and
documented the importance of more risk
capital investment for job creation and
for the ability of these companies to
get started and grow then I went to
Washington and testified before Congress
and there was a young congressman from
Wisconsin Bill Steiger who was on the
House Ways and Means Committee and he
became intrigued with this idea of
lowering the tax on capital gains and so
he introduced a bill to do so and I
worked with him and my the whole
Electronics Association worked in
lobbying the Mait Ways and Means
Committee worked with the Senate and by
November of 1978 about a year after we'd
started this process with our survey the
federal tax on capital gains was lowered
from 50% to 28% and within about 18
months 1 billion dollars of capital
flowed into professionally managed
venture capital funds compared to the 50
million a year that had been happening
during the 70's and anybody who studies
the 1980s that number on an annual basis
four or five billion a year flowing into
funds that were supporting new
enterprises and job-creating enterprises
so that experience particularly because
bill Steiger died of a heart attack
within a month after this bill was
passed you know he passed away in early
December of 1978 the bill was passed in
November of 78 his example
inspired me to for public service he had
changed the nature of the debate in
Washington on tax policy from who pays
and who doesn't
to what will be the economic impact and
I felt gosh somebody who has built a
company somebody's had the experience
that I had with working with Bill
stargher to get the tax rate on capital
gains reduced perhaps I had a
contribution to make in public service
it also strikes me and I think you may
have even said this in an interview that
I read in preparing for this
conversation that in in a very real
sense you had an advantage in the sense
that you could always go back to
building companies right it which means
you weren't necessarily dedicated to
being a politician as a career
indefinitely from that point forward you
had very you had some attractive Plan
B's or plan C's if it didn't work out so
did that enable you to think more
aggressively or differently well I had a
personal principle that I was only going
to stay in the House of Representatives
atmo
three terms six years and that gave me
two advantages one a sense of urgency
I couldn't just kind of wait it round
and and it's learn the ropes I had to
start making a difference as quickly as
I was able and secondly I gave me the
freedom to do what I thought was right
the worst could happen as I get retired
or maybe it's the best that could happen
I get retired after one term or two
terms certainly I wasn't going to serve
more than three as it turned out I only
serve two terms in the house because as
a congressman from California I think
there were at that time 48 or 50
California members of the House of
Representatives and we were a dime a
dozen yeah they're just and it was very
difficult for a single California
congressman or congresswoman to get the
message out so I felt that if I have
ideas I don't not only need a message I
need a megaphone and I decided that I
could get a megaphone if I became a US
senator from California I ran for the US
Senate in 19 starts in a tea sitting on
85 for the 1986 campaign I won the
Republican nomination but I was defeated
in a very close election about a
percentage point percentage point and a
half by the three-term incumbent Alan
Cranston and looking back I was
disappointed at the time because I felt
I wasn't as a good enough candidate I
had lots of support and I'd like people
down but
looking back I dodged a bullet with that
very close loss because since then I
feel through leading companies and
through at least my view changing lives
for the better my students over many
many years that I may have through not
just their lives but how they've changed
in a positive way the lives of others
that I may have made more of a
contribution to a better future than I
would have as a u.s. senator I believe
that I definitely believe that and
arsons a end but at the time you were
disappointed and I would be very
interested to hear because we've been
talking about a lot of your successes
and you've had a lot of successes but at
that time when you got the news that you
had lost what did the next few days or
weeks look like for you what did you
what do you say to yourself when you
when when you have when you experienced
a loss like that what do I do next to
make a difference and I'd never been out
of a job I mean when you think about it
it was from teaching to starting a
company to running for Congress and now
I was I didn't have a next what am I
going to do next and I had the
opportunity to join the venture capital
firm that was the lead investor in my
first company and I accepted that
assignment as a General Partner of the
firm
it was Brentwood associates at that time
was a los angeles-based venture capital
firm and I established the Silicon
Valley office of that firm I think they
my partners would agree that I wasn't
really very good
being a venture capital investor I'm too
much of an optimist every deal I looked
at oh gee that it that's really
interesting I can see how to make that
happen and as a venture capitalist you
really have to be more realistic and
maybe even super critical but also at
that time in my life I viewed being an
investor as kind of like a football
coach you walk the sidelines you send in
plays you make substitutions you rant
and rave at halftime but you never put
any points on the board and I was still
in at that time of my life wanting to
put points on the board meaning running
a company not being the better in the
stands but the jockey on the horse and
so when I had an opportunity to become
CEO of one of the companies Brentwood
had it helped to start I I took that
opportunity and a company in the
magnetic recording components business
called cents store how do you make what
is your decision process like for
something like that because you
mentioned with the venture capital
general partner position perhaps you are
too optimistic everything sounded
interesting but when you make a decision
to say become the CEO of a start-up in
the portfolio you're saying no to other
things presumably so what was the
decision process like in evaluating that
and saying yes to it well it's it's it's
again commitment I mean I was part of a
firm General Partner of a firm that had
made a significant investment in this
company and they felt that there was a
need for a new CEO and so when they
talked to me about it it started out as
well can you go in there
help out and be on the board and it
evolved into can you go in there and run
it and I wasn't gonna say nose of my
partner's did you in your mind or
explicitly with them set expectations in
the way that you did for yourself with
the three-term limit as as a congressman
did you go in to it saying I'm
committing to this for X period of time
and then we'll reevaluate or was it left
totally open-ended I was left open and
the the goal is success rather than how
long and I think you're getting to an
issue that where I may not be like a lot
of other people I don't do things for me
I do things for others so if you want to
get down to what motivates you finding
something that I think is meaningful
that needs to be done and recognizing I
can help do it and it's not about the
money that's why I do things pro bono my
wife is not particularly thrilled with
that approach but on the other hand I
it's I focus on where can I make a
difference for the benefit of others
rather than what's in it for me and I
don't know whether that's unusual but it
served me well how do you differentiate
between the things that will have the
greatest impact for others and feeling
pure pressured to commit to something if
that question makes any sense because it
seems like it seems like people pleasing
and committing to things that will help
the greatest number of other people or
deeply help other people are two
different things and I guess
I'm just wondering if if there are times
when you commit to say doing certain
things because the general partners to
whom you've made a commitment ask you to
do it may not always be the same thing
that will have the greatest impact maybe
it's not a good question I'm just
wondering if you've ever run into a
position where people want you to do one
thing and you could be very good at it
but you feel like your your abilities
are better put in a different place yeah
usually the decisions that I make about
how I'm gonna spend my time and my life
are made by me rather than responding to
requests when I came to offer my course
here at Princeton I hadn't gotten a
phone call saying hey ed would you
please come and teach a high tech
entrepreneurship course at Princeton
rather in June of 1997 I asked for a
meeting with them Dean of the
engineering school James way and in that
meeting I proposed that the engineering
school would benefit from having a
rather comprehensive program in
entrepreneurship it just made perfect
sense to me that engineers innovate but
in order to make a difference in the
world that innovation has to then become
real and commercialized and often in a
start-up venture so exposing engineering
students to that process and that
opportunity seemed to make sense and
that was the origin of the first
offering of vol II 491 in the fall
semester of 1997 again an instance where
I decided that there might be some value
that I could create and now
Princeton entrepreneurship the Princeton
way is pervasive across this campus with
many courses with any co-curricular and
extracurricular programs for the benefit
of student entrepreneurs and the survey
that I mentioned before out of 400 of
the students that took my course
forgetting about not including the
courses the many other courses that are
now offered to have a hundred and sixty
founders of companies from that cadre it
would suggest to me that out of the
total of 1600s that there may be three
four hundred founders and I still I'm
touched when I got emails from students
I may have had a dozen years ago saying
Edie you planted the seed twelve years
ago and it's finally sprouting I have
just founded my first company it took me
this long but you gave me the confidence
to do it how have you thought about
parenting and your own kids because
you're you've you you're so deliberate
in how you teach and you've prepared so
extensively not just for the courses but
for each individual class how have you
thought about parenting or how would you
describe your parenting style it's it's
almost the same that it's just that the
students start a lot younger I believe
that the best way to help people find
their way nurture them is through
encouragement rather than direction but
when I was when our children were young
and we have three children I coached 13
soccer teams with all three of them
played soccer at one time or another I
was a Cub Scout leader and a Boy Scout
leader and the we're really proud of the
way our kids turned out we were lucky
they were growing up in a good place at
a good time probably not a lot of the
challenges that all parents face today
with the world more complicated with
communications technology more advanced
but loving them caring and letting them
know that you love them and you care is
it's kind of the secret of parenting
could you speak to the encouragement
instead of rather than Direction a bit
more does that mean that you're exposing
them to a lot and whatever they
gravitate towards naturally is what you
then try to foster what does that mean
when you say encouragement stead of
direction well they've got to live their
lives
you can't live their lives and I think I
benefited a lot from my own parents they
were proud of me whether I did well or
not I learned when I was maybe five six
seven years old how to build radios and
build motors in a basement workshop from
my father who had a degree in electrical
engineering but sadly during the
Depression he lost his engineering job
and got into a assignment that really
didn't have anything to do with
engineering
but he stayed in it in order to provide
for his family one thing that I remember
from my parents I was as we talked about
earlier a competitive figure skater and
sometimes I didn't do well in a
competition I may fall on I may have not
done a school figure very well not upto
my ability
they never criticized me in those
situations they never put pressure on me
they were always supportive and proud
regardless of how well I did relative to
what I could have done what might they
say let's just say on the car ride back
after he had for you disappointing
performance what what what are the types
of things they might say to you great
job great job and having been a soccer
coach I know that not all parents act
that way sometimes parents are the
problem the players are just fine
parents are a problem but both of my
parents weren't raised by their parents
my mother was raised by her grandmother
my father was raised by his mother's
sister his mother died when he was about
12 years old his father was in the
German newspaper business in Montana but
he and his sister grew up in Omaha
raised by his deceased mother's sister
and I think as a result of their not
having parents they wanted to be the
best parents and so my sister we never
had a whole lot of money but my sister
had ballet lessons and she was an
exquisite ballerina
I had piano lessons
figure skating lessons and they just
wanted to be the best parents ever and I
think they felt blessed to have two
children who wanted to succeed you know
we both studied hard we were both good
students we went to college we did other
things besides that and and we want to
both want as our parents to be proud
where do you think that desire came from
was it watching their example and the
perhaps the diligence with which your
father showed you how to disassemble and
reassemble these radios what we're did
the desire to please them come from if
what you most received was continuous
positive feedback I'm not I'm not sure
it was the focus of my life was to
please them right or for them but I've
I've had from the time I was in grade
school maybe even in kindergarten first
grade
an overarching goal and and that is to
live a life that matters to make a
lasting positive difference in the world
I call it leaving footprints and that's
what drives me so some people might say
well my overarching goal is to be the
richest person around or my overarching
goal is to have a whole lot of adulation
and be a celebrity my goal maybe even in
a quiet way is to leave footprints on
the world have there ever been times in
your life where you felt like you've
wandered or been pushed away from that
and then have corrected course I don't
recall
I don't recall I've always sort of
marched to my own drum yeah you know one
of that's another thing and is important
of for your audience I always wanted to
be different there are people
particularly with social media these
days that want to be accepted that want
to be like others if someone has a new
kind of shoe or shirt every you know
others want to have the same thing and
so I've always had a desire to be
different from others and maybe that
enables me not only to venture where
others may not venture but also to be
satisfied doing something that nobody
else is doing are there any books that
have had a particularly large impact on
your life or that you've given the most
to other people or recommended well the
4-hour workweek for our body those are
very fine books and everyone should read
them besides those of course on the top
shelf are there are there any any any
books that come to mind that have
impacted you strongly or that you've
recommended to students or other people
when I was little when I'm talking about
little like six eight ten years old
there was a whole series of biographies
written for children my age Thomas
Edison Abraham Lincoln Benjamin Franklin
and I would read those books over and
over because they their lives and what
they accomplished were what I hope to do
so it was that set of experiences there
was a book on the Wright brothers and
these were written for somebody my age
now you can read Walter Isaacson's book
on Benjamin Franklin or on Steve Jobs or
Walter Isaacson's book on Einstein and
but it's the same thing you know our
David McCullough's on the Wright
brothers yes a fabulous book do you
still read biographies dude is that
that's kind of all I care about
and it's the stories the stories that
are inspirational and it gets back to
what we were talking about before with
the case method where when I'm reading a
biography just like I'm hoping the
students when they read a case that they
think of themselves in that situation
and what would I do
and reading biographies well it is a
wonderful makalah book on the Wright
brothers amazing lessons of they didn't
just go out build a plane and fly it a
lot of setbacks and disappointments and
struggles in order to do what they did
the same with I mean all of those the it
gets to what we were talking about
before the preparation the commitment to
excellence it doesn't happen overnight
people who achieve great things even
though it may look like it happened
quickly and easily and everybody can do
it most of those still
Rory's have a lot of sacrifice and
difficulty and disappointments and
setbacks in them for entrepreneurs
whether students in your classes or
people listening are there any
particular biographies or books you
would recommend in particular and he's
any standouts or like or just particular
figures well again
don't buy the books because they have
lessons in them buy the books because
they have stories in them and there are
a bunch of them my colleague at
Princeton Derek ladow has written a
couple of books and his most recent is
built on bedrock and it's a lot of the
book is about Walmart and Sam Walton and
how it started and he went to the
Walmart archives and and based his
stories about Walmart on those facts and
but it's it's filled with stories about
companies that were built by people on
solid foundations built on bedrock I had
a chance either the stories are so
important I think also for for many
reasons of course but also because it's
really the glue that we as humans are
programmed to use to remember any of the
lessons that might come out of those
stories and that's something that struck
me when a few months ago I was invited
to go to Bentonville Arkansas and
interviewed Doug McMillon the CEO of
Walmart for this podcast but was my
first time in Northwest Arkansas my
first time in Ben Ville and I went to
the I was able to see Sam Waltons pickup
truck and the keys and the stories are
what stick and it was a fascinating
fascinating experience
what are you most excited about these
days I mean you're you seem to be moving
as quickly doing as many things as ever
you certainly don't strike me as someone
who's ever idle what are you personally
most excited about these days
well I'm focusing now on education and
my years of teaching are just part of it
but you look at higher education today
very expensive a lot of students would
may not be prepared for first jobs may
not be prepared for a lifetime of
contributions and so just in the last
couple of weeks I volunteered to be the
interim president of a wonderful small
College Sierra Nevada College located in
Incline Village Nevada right on the
shores of Lake Tahoe in the midst of the
Sierra Nevada mountains and this is a
college that has a dedicated faculty
with real life experience in the areas
they teach they're not just teachers
they've done what they teach it is a
College in which entrepreneurship is
pervasive it has some real focused
capabilities in environmental science
well right there on the shores of Lake
Tahoe keep Tahoe blue environmental
science is critical in that area what a
wonderful place to learn about that it
has a strong entrepreneurial based
business
program at the undergraduate level and
then it has a marvelous fine arts and
creative writing program you don't go
there to major in neuroscience you don't
go there to major in philosophy but if
you want to go to a small college with
small classes with dedicated teachers
and to be an entrepreneurial leader both
in your first job and for a lifetime of
contributions in establishing and and
building enterprises or being a leading
environmental scientists with
entrepreneurial approaches to that
scientific work or if you want to be
like a writer you know him better than
anybody writers aren't just writers
they're entrepreneurs to the creating
content but then getting their content
read and podcasting that's a way of
communicating with people I have friends
who are photographers they became
photographers they didn't born
photographers but they became
photographers but there are
entrepreneurs so here's a small college
that I've volunteered to lead until a
successor with entrepreneurial
leadership capabilities is identified
and takes office and continue to promote
this higher education approach one of
the challenges these days as I just
mentioned was how do we do this less
expensively and I believe that there are
ways in which education can use
technology to
reduce the costs I'm not advocating well
there will never be any more classrooms
but a combination of that classroom
experience with online learning can
reduce the costs of providing a
top-rated educational institution
I'm also attracted to income sharing
agreements perhaps your audience is not
familiar with them but rather than
taking out student loans there are
sources of financing where the student
signs an agreement that to repay based
on their income and above certain levels
and if they never make that much they
don't repay but if they make more than
that threshold level then they pay and
may pay more than the the amount of the
the debt but having students graduating
with huge amounts of debt reduces their
choices and you asked me earlier well
how do you choose what you want to do
well I want to change the world I want
to do things that will benefit others
well if you have a lot of debt you may
not be able to make those choices that
are in that direction you have to focus
first on well how do I make them enough
money to pay off my debt so and I don't
know whether any of the people who are
listening to this podcast are thinking
about enrolling in a unique educational
institution but we do have a few
openings left for entering freshmen this
even this fall in late August so if
there are people who are interested in
coming to get a uniquely valuable
educational experience in a beautiful
setting
look up Sierra Nevada dot e-d-u
and I'll link to that in the show notes
for everyone as well so you'll be able
to find those links really easily the
income sharing is very very interesting
to me I don't have much exposure to it
but there are some programming schools
for instance I believe one is called
lambda school which has this exact model
and has proven very very successful it
also puts a very productive onus on the
educators to really think through the
practicalities of what they're teaching
how effective they are how effectively
they're imparting these these skills to
their students do you have any
particular quotes or mantras anything
that you live your life by or remind
yourself of often are there any
particular I mean you mentioned say one
earlier if you're failing to prepare
you're preparing to fail do you have any
other any other quotes that have have
really stuck with you do what you enjoy
doing do it the best you know how good
things will happen I love it now but I I
may be unusual well I don't know whether
I'm this unusual I like to get out of my
comfort zone do things I haven't done
before I believe that doing so enables
me to learn but the more I learn the
more I'm able to contribute to others so
do doing the same thing and and being
able to be the best at that
that's laudable but my mother had a
problem with me when she was alive she
so I I started out with this teaching I
mentioned how I got into it the Stanford
Graduate School of Business and after
I'd done that for a while I said mom
I'm gonna start a company and she said
buzzy that was my nickname and my sister
still calls me buzzy and my high school
friends call me buzzy buzzy you were
just getting good at teaching and and
now you're gonna start a company you
don't know anything about that and then
the company did okay and we took it
public and I said mother I'm gonna run
for Congress buzzy you were just getting
good at running a company you don't know
anything about politics and she lived
long enough so that she saw may sworn
into the US House of Representatives in
January of 1983 and then she passed away
that April Wow how did she how did she
respond to seeing you sworn in well she
she was not she didn't express her
emotions and her feelings a lot but I
believe she was proud I'm sure she was
how could she not be yeah you have a an
incredible tradition that I think is so
suiting to you and it's so memorable for
so many of your students and it has to
do with singing and it seems like there
have been a few different versions of
this but where did the singing enter the
picture with your your teaching well it
started way before the start way before
that oh yeah when I was probably in
grade school I would write poems about
things
like the busy bee is lively all he does
is buzz but yesterday he stung me and
now he is a was way back and then I
started composing or using music that
already existed then when I was in first
teaching at the Stanford Graduate School
of Business
there there was a tradition there where
in the spring in May they held a joint
faculty student event called the Spring
Fling and the faculty would prepare a
skit and it had perhaps acting it had
perhaps some songs and I became the
writer for the faculty skits and then
there were students kits as well and my
most famous song I wrote many in for
those skits about various courses and
well primarily about courses but then
I'd also write the words and we had a
take-off on Batman and Robin and we had
a Mission Impossible skit and with where
I'd write the songs and the music and
even after I left the faculty they as a
teacher
they kept and I'd started my company
they kept me on the Stanford Business
School faculty from the time I left
which was 1970 to 1981 so I could
continue to be the writer of the faculty
that's good
well the most famous song I wrote was
about the linear programming algorithm
how to it was called the simplex method
where poor students in 1966 when I was
teaching the quantitative methods course
had to learn how to do this and linear
programming was abbreviated LT linear
programming and so I wrote a song about
the algorithm that was mathematically
correct that if you listened to the
words you could do the simplex algorithm
to achieve an optimal solution to a
linear programming problem but I wrote
it in the form of a dance and it went
something like this come on gang now
gather round see what your math profs
putting down getting close and listen to
me I'm gonna show you how to do the LP
it's a new dance but it's easily done in
fact you learned it in 261 just to make
sure that you can do it listen close
while I review it do the LP come on baby
do the LP with me we're going to pivot
step day and night and optimizes out of
sight and then it went through a series
of verses with details of the simplex
algorithm first of all form a big strong
line I that's it you're looking fine
fine behind that line form one more come
on everybody get out on the floor keep
forming lines one after one when you're
out of cats then you're done now you see
how I get my kicks
I've got y'all in a big matrix do the LP
come on baby do the LP with me we're
going to pivot step day and night and
optimize it is out of sight incredible
see you you use stories you use music I
feel like I feel like these these are
communication skills that are trans I
transcend the era in which you were born
I mean these you could have gone back a
thousand years and used these could
probably go forward a thousand years and
use these and your students remember
these things they really remember these
things and I'd love for you to talk
about another song that I certainly was
exposed to and that is my way and why
you chose that song
well again I was teaching at Harvard
Business School in 1996 a course called
entrepreneurial finance and for the last
class of the course I wanted and with a
number of stories and and share with
students my philosophies and it was a
captive audience attendance was
mandatory and I I thought what would be
an appropriate message to convey and
that message we've talked about it
earlier parenting teaching the message
is just do it your way and so then I
thought of the song my way and I put
some words to that song
this courses end is here but I have in
this final session sought for your
career it is a most important lesson as
you go down life's path whether slow
we call the Nike and just do it your way
uh it brings back the memories and I and
it not just it not only brings back the
memories but it it just refreshes the
mark that you had on me and continue to
have and I I really just want to thank
you
edy for doing things your way it's
really had such an incredible impact on
so many people and I I'm not going to
mention it by name but he's a mutual
friend of ours you introduced us because
we were both we were both students of
yours but I will he's a very very very
successful entrepreneur and we were
going back and forth emailing in
preparation for this this interview with
you and he in closing
says please give my best to add any
success I've had in business was due to
him that is an incredible sentence and
it's incredible also because he is not
the only student who would write that
I've met students of yours from China
I've met students of yours from
countries around the world who have some
version of that sentiment and it's so
incredible and it's been such a
privilege and such a great stroke of
luck
that I ended up in your class and I just
want to say that to you because it's had
such a significant impact on the
trajectory of my life and certainly for
me that's a big deal that's a really
really big deal so thank you you thank
you Tim and now you know why I do what I
do I've I concluded a long time ago I'm
not gonna be able to change the world
alone I said my goal in life is to live
a life that matters I call leaving
footprints
but I can better achieve my goal leaving
footprints with your feet and so that's
why I do what I do
well Edie I hope this is certainly I
mean I can't wait to have dinner we're
gonna have dinner after this and
continue to catch up I can't wait to see
what you do next and I'm so so happy to
have a chance to spend time together
today and this has been a real pleasure
for me to do this well I'm proud of you
too and I'm proud of so many people who
you refer to who have taken my course
they've taken many other courses they've
had other experiences but they go out
and do great stuff and deep down I say
to myself well I'm really glad I lost
that Senate race otherwise I may not
have been able to do what I've been
doing yeah oh I sound strange to say but
I'm also glad I'm really glad for my
sake and for the sake of many people
that you lost that Senate race and
you've just done so much so much good
and you're gonna continue to do so much
good it's really inspiring and I think
this is a great place to to wrap up is
there anything else you would like to
say or close with anything you'd like to
recommend to people anything at all that
you'd like to to say before we wrap up
well I've told you my story and with you
know some detail that based on Tim's
questions but most important thing for
you to do you speaking to the audience
is to do it your way
don't just follow what it's recommended
don't just pursue what others are
pursuing but do what you enjoy doing do
it the best you know how good things
will happen and if you're thinking more
about doing something different than
you're currently doing it's time for a
change can I could not imagine a better
place to close Edie to be continued
we're gonna go grab some food and
continue the conversation but thank you
so much for taking the time to do this
oh this is a real treat - and I noticed
that there's a blackboard that's dirty
and erasers that need cleaning so get to
it yes literally a whiteboard right
behind me so I'm gonna get get back to
my my other tasks cleaning up for Edie
and to be continued and to everybody
listening I will include everything
we've talked about in the show notes
which you can find as always at Tim da
blog forward slash podcast and I hope
you enjoyed this even half as much as I
did and thank you so much for tuning in
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday event provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles
that I haven't read and that I've shared
with my close friends for instance and
it's very short it's just a little tiny
bite of goodness before you head off for
the weekend so if you want to receive
that check it out just go to 4-hour
workweek comm that's four hour workweek
comm all spelled out and just drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one and if you sign up I hope you enjoy
it
this episode of the Tim Ferriss show is
brought to you by 99designs 99designs is
a global creative platform makes it easy
for you to find an amazing designer and
create designs you'll love logos
branding - packaging - books you name it
they have it and I've used them for just
about everything 99 designs is the go to
creative resource for any budget I use
them for years now I'll put covers for
instance mock-ups of before our body
which went on to become a number one New
York Times bestseller illustrations for
the multi-volume cow of Seneca including
the cover and many other creative
projects have been very impressed by the
quality of their work most recently I
used 99 designs to update the
illustrations and layout of my 5 morning
rituals eBook the illustrations worked
out great I love to work with a designer
reflected and I plan to work with him on
wall projects in the future and that's
something you can do you don't have to
start from scratch every time and right
now my listeners can get $20 off plus a
free $99 upgrade on their first design
contest simply submit a brief on the
site describing what you need and
designers who are interested in your
project often from around the world will
submit concepts for you to choose from
you'll find as you go give feedback and
once you're ready you choose one to
finalize it's a great way to get started
and find the right match a great
designer and a great design at a great
price so head to 99 designs com forward
slash Tim to learn more or get started
today you can also see examples of some
of the work
I have done with designers on undead
sides let's check it out
99designs comm /y tip this episode is
brought to you by Paulo time I love
peloton peloton is a cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings live studio
classes right to your home you don't
have to worry about fitting classes into
your schedule making it to the studio or
dealing with some commute to the gym I
have a peloton bike in my master bedroom
at home and it is one of the first
things that I do in the morning I wake
up meditate for some 20 minutes and then
I knock out a short 20 minute ride
usually high-intensity interval training
or kit then I take shower and I'm in
higher gear for the rest of the day it's
beautifully convenient and has become
something that I actually looked forward
to and I was skeptical in the beginning
I didn't think I would dig it and I
really do oh you have a lot of options
for one if you like you can ride alive
with thousands of other pollen riders
from across the country on the
interactive leaderboard keep you
motivated I tend to use a lot of the
classes on demand and have four to six
of them that I've bookmarked and use
over and over again there are up to 14
new classes every day with thousands of
classes on demand and there are a
variety of workouts to choose from 45
minute classes 20 minute burns hip hop
rock and roll low impact or
high-intensity pick the class structure
and style their works for you
peloton has an amazing roster of
incredible instructors in your city
included you have great instructors of
every possible personality style and
that you can find one that you love no
matter what you're in the mood for
personally I use Matt Walker's a lot but
I use a bunch of them I'm promiscuous
and enjoy classes from a lot of their
instructors with real time metrics you
can track your performance over time and
continue to be your personal best I did
not think the gamification would work
for me and they really hit the nail on
the head it does work at least for me
tremendously well to keep you pushing
consistently so discover this cutting
edge indoor cycling bike that brings us
to to experience to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
calm that's spelled Oh
PTL oto and calm enter the code tim
podcast all one word at checkout and get
$100 off accessories with your peloton
bike purchase get a great workout at
home any time you want to go to one
peloton calm and use the code tim
podcast to get started
[Applause]